you started off as a model and
and now seemingly sort of come full
circle
um what was that journey like for you i
mean for me you know obviously
being from lubbock grove you know sort
of a very protective
family and then being thrown out into
sort of late 80s london
as a teenage model and i always say i
sort of lived in two worlds you know i
lived in my home
just you know ghanaian and ghanaian
foods and
garnet music and then out in the world
in england so i feel that i feel this
duality has sort of
really defined who i am over the years
um
it was hard for my parents because you
know they wanted me to be a lawyer
it's been a very long journey but i
always wanted to include people of all
races
all colors i always call it you know the
marginalized or the other
you've spoken in the past about um your
life growing up in in labor grove
and sometimes being frightened in that
environment
because of who you were i mean you know
growing up in sort of
eighties love grove was a was a
different time you know
we had to be sort of very careful um you
know we had to be careful with the
police walking down the wrong street
you know things like life crimes
i had a great role model i had
great uncles i had my dad and i had
people to look
up to so you know when i went out and
things weren't so great i always had a
great
family but you grew up aware of of
racism of course
you know i think everybody who's black
in england is aware of racism growing up
but for me every
challenge i faced i would never
sort of sit back and give up i didn't
come from that kind of fun i always
thought okay i'll show you i'll break
through and i'll do it with my
work and i'll deal with my talent and so
for me that's really the continuous
journey
never saying you know i couldn't do
something if you told me i couldn't do
something
i'll definitely show you i could you've
been quite frank in your experiences
you've tweeted about you know being at a
fashion show and not being sat
on the front row with your peers i mean
that was quite brave of you
when you look at my work from the age of
18 i've always
been very true to myself i'd be always
be very authentic about my feelings
in that particular case you know when
you walk into a show
and all fashion directors are in the
front row and you're in the second world
straight away that's you
you know profiling me um even
a few weeks ago the same thing sort of
happened the incident that you're
referring to
in the office when you're racially
profiled by a security guard in your
your own office
how did you feel when that happened it
wasn't an isolated incident of course
you know it takes you back to all those
moments in your life when that has
happened
and i think people people think that
when you're successful
that things like that don't happen for
me the beauty of that incident is it
just makes me aware
never to think i'm too successful
that it can happen any day and i have to
be really alert
and deal with it really and what would
you say to
to those that say you know your your
success is
an armor against racism and you know
things like that don't happen to to
people like you
but obviously as we saw the other day
does happen from my tweets
it's important that something like this
did happen because it reminds me
never to think i'm yeah like i said too
successful
or too well known or too established
because
to somebody you're another black person
and i really didn't want all the young
kids in
the building to have to face that first
black
editor of british vogue first male
editor of british vogue um lots of
firsts
in your your armory um are you
comfortable
with being described as a pioneer
oh god okay um
i just like to think that you know i
i've contributed to the conversation
i've contributed to you know the world
of fashion and imagery
and by doing that i've been able to sort
of shine their lives on
shining light on the marginalized
marginalized groups you know people
who've been othered
that's really what i i'm most proud of
making
everybody a part of the conversation and
are you happy
to um be described as political that the
magazine
does have a statement to make now about
our current conditions
i wouldn't say political but i think we
you i do use the platform
to address injustices um you know to
talk about you know
people's rights so you know like we said
before you know
social rights you know trans rights you
know the people we feature you know
zadie smith salmon we're not shy we
don't shy away from controversy but
on the other hand it's all through a
vogue lens
to the highest quality and you know
running alongside all that we still have
the incredible fashion stories the
incredible
images you know designer profiles for me
and my team
who are sort of a diverse team the mix
is the most important for me
tell us about the september issue the
the concept the idea behind it
and and what has materialized so the
september issue is a very special one
we went from sort of we went from you
know covey to talking about
environmental issues
to the biggest moment in civil rights
history i mean
the whole world of the marches
and i felt like these incredible
people who were sort of
given their time and their lives to make
sure
that there was social justice in the
world to make sure that there was
education and community care
these were the people who were the new
heroes
and what we perhaps previously deemed as
ordinary
became extraordinary ordinary is now so
extraordinary
and that's what what i love about what
we're able to do about
you know we've been able to pivot still
keep it vogue but talk about issues that
really
matter as well and the september issue
um the front cover tell us who's on the
front cover and and also the the
collaborations be
behind the scenes as well yes i mean the
issue was shot by
the cover was shot by a photographer
called nissan harriman
um he's a black photographer styled by
my fashion editor
donna wallis and it was an all black
team
we have marcus you know the footballer
from manchester
you know i mean he literally used his
platform to get
all the young kids fed that we have
adjusboa
um they're on the sort of the main cover
you know and address used
her platform to talk about mental health
for me
thinking you know as an editor for a
fashion magazine how
i knew i couldn't just have handbags and
shoes
it just felt like we needed to create a
document of this time
this incredible time of change obviously
during the pandemic we had the black
lives matter
marches and you actually went out on a
march didn't you
i mean you know i live opposite hyde
park so i put my mask on
and i went and you know it was the most
peaceful
you know people sat on the floor john
boyega spoke and it was so peaceful
people of all colors and all races were
there
and what really struck me about that day
about how
you know that george floyd's death
hasn't been in vain it brought
everyone together do you feel positive
now that that things
might change that the systemic racism
that that we've seen i mean i feel
that's changed
racism and i feel that people are aware
now
you know maybe perhaps you know it
wasn't in people's faces but now you
know everybody knows
racism is not just an american problem
you know it's also a british problem
it's a global problem and that's what
these marches
sort of you know showed everyone you did
work with the dutchess of sussex
and that issue the special industry that
you did with her
and she came in for a lot of criticism
for that
would you put that down to racism no i
mean i think you know
you know the duchess of sussex is very
she's a brave woman she's a brave woman
i feel that it wasn't the part of
probably raising them but it was more
institution you know she walked into an
institution
and everybody expected her to know the
rules and i think sometimes it takes a
minute to
sort of understand the rules but she did
get a very
unfair treatment i thought you feel that
it was unfair that the way she was
criticized
it was harsh but i wouldn't i wouldn't
just blame it on racism
black lives matter uh racism people
how they've been perceived and and how
they've been judged
in society are you hopeful now that
there
will be other edward ennin falls coming
behind you that people will feel that
the doors have been opened
i will make sure there is for me it's
been so important just
not being the only one but always
bringing people up with me and i think
it's so important you know the fashion
industry needs to you know employ more
people behind the scenes
recruitment you know has to change and i
think once we have people behind the
scenes there will be
more than ever then in falls you know
but we need more people behind the
scenes i think it's not enough
just having you know sort of black
people on your instagram feed or in a
magazine we've you know we've
accomplished that
but now you know behind the scenes
that's when change really happens
and is that the idea behind the
september issue having a full
black cast contribute i mean the
subsequent issue for me was really to
talk about the times we we're in now in
the in
the world we were in so you know if that
happens from that i am so happy really
and i hope it does
edward enfield thank you very much thank
you for having me